300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah subhanahu wa
tala's book like you've never had before
salaam alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing inshallah
before i start one praise allah the most
most of the most trust or praise his
glory and gratitude belong to him
today's video is very very profound the
reason it's profound sisters is if you
think about it actually
one of the prophecies of the prophet
salallahu sallam has actually come to be
and that is what
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi said
that one of the signs of the hour is
that a time would come that people we
will be having sex zinna out in the open
public
and amongst them would be
the one that's most righteous amongst
them would come and say at least go
behind the bushes and do what you're
doing and that's one what
among the most righteous amongst them
and that times will be the one that will
come and say go and do it behind the
wall or behind the bushes yeah imagine
the times we're going to be living in
that one of the most righteous ones
should we say uh in that in that like
you know only righteous well the best
you know is going to come and tell you
to go and do it behind somewhere else
mexico city has legalized this why
because they say that they want the
police to be concentrating on more of a
serious crimes yeah other crimes like
drugs or whatever it may be subhanallah
this is what it shows you that today
roman says it has come to that they are
legalizing certain things so police can
deal with bigger matters this is
a violation to allah subhanahu ta'ala's
in islam a person can in their house
commit zina whatever etc yeah because
that's the private space when you're
promoting it you see
the consequences brown sisters that when
you don't enjoy good and forbid evil
that this is what happens and that's why
the prophet saw sallallahu sallam said
you either enjoying good and forbid evil
or allah will send down a calamity that
even if you're frustrated be rejected
from you this is how deep in joining god
of forbidden evil is because other
nations have stopped this and because
they've stopped this you see it
rampant everywhere why people are doing
all kinds of stuff because if we don't
go around
and advise we don't want to enforce
anybody advise being our sisters or our
brothers don't do this don't do that
what happens is the norm at least when
you advise them they are shy we have
come to a point in our life that for me
to go and advise our brother and sister
in a haram relationship i feel shy they
don't feel shy of doing that and i'm shy
of approaching them this is the state
that we've come to enjoying and good and
for being evil is fundamental if we see
a brother doing something drinking
alcohol it's my duty and my job to
continue above this is wrong this is
wrong if i see a sister who might be
doing something wrong it's my job to
advise them
but subhanallah i'm not going to keep
this video too long but you can see that
this is one of the signs of the day of
judgement and all the minor signs all of
them have nearly done
and it's the major signs and the
prophets peace be upon him told us the
major signs are going to be like a bead
when you cut it they're all going to
fall one after another all of them going
to happen one after another and we ask
allah to protect us and this shows that
the the prophethood of prophet peace be
upon him is from allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala he's a true prophet he's
prophesied so many things and every
single one of them have come true and
today we have seen the day in the 21st
century that a country has legalized
having sex and zina out in the open with
no shame may allah protect us and
protect our children and our family
members from this filth till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi